hello everyone uh
my name is ali lashvaripor and i'm a
freshly
mentioned phd from a cider lab at boston
university department of biomedical
engineering
and today i want to talk about the
research i've been doing
over the past five years on machine
learning based design
automation of microfluidic flow focusing
droplet generators
um so um i've done my research
in cider lab which stands for
cross-disciplinary integration of design
automation
research and as you guessed it we are
a diverse background of engineers in
biomedical computer and electronic
engineering and mechanical engineering
and the glue that holds us all together
apart from our pi doug densmore
is synthetic biology and
design automation so
synthetic biology in its simplest form
is
where we get inspired by natural
biofunctions and try
to engineer them to create either
optimized or novel functionalities
that solve our biorelated problems
and crispr technology is a great example
of
synthetic biology where dr dodnan and dr
sharpentier
were inspired by the natural defense
mechanisms of
of bacteria against viruses to to create
this
technology for gene editing and they
received the nobel prize for it last
year
it has also many applications for
example we can
create microbes that produce biodiesel
in a very sustainable way we can have
tailored crops that have additional
nutritional or medicinal value we can
also
detect pathogens and contaminants early
on in our
crops so we avoid losing a lot of our
crop
we can have lab grown meat we can have
sustainable fashion in terms of
both the fabric itself and the fabric
coloring and
even we can have lab grown meat
so synthetic biology itself is a really
a challenging field we're trying to
optimize and
improve upon something that life has 3.5
billion years to
to develop so typically scientists go
through the
design build and test cycle and because
this is a challenging task this is a
challenging test
uh uh tools can really accelerate this
design built
uh test cycle for synthetic biologists
and
insider lab uh we actually develop tools
for
uh for design automation of these
synthetic circuits so you can have
high-level description of what
functionality you want
uh your synthetic circuit to carry out
and then
um different candidates would be
proposed by the tool
that you can later assemble and test we
have tools like puppeteer
that can provide instruction for
assembling
these synthetic circuits either with
manual assembly or using
automated liquid handling robots and
then finally we are developing tools for
a microfluidic-based testing of these
uh specific circuits and my talk is
going to be
focused on the testing section and the
reason for that
is um well over the past years our
ability
to uh sort of build more and more
complex
uh synthetic dna has been uh growing
exponentially and also uh
the cost of dna synthesis and dna
sequencing has been going
down in the uh past year so
testing uh is now kind of a bottleneck
where we can sort of build
these synthetic circuits faster faster
than we can
test them and you can see that in the
review papers
recently came out or interviews with
major players in the field where a good
testing platform
could significantly accelerate
can significantly accelerate the
discovery cycle and scientific biology
so drop the droplet-based microfluidics
are a great example or or a great
candidate for
high throughput screening and high
throughput testing
in uh in synthetic biology where we can
basically encapsulates cells inside of
our
picoliter and even nanoliter droplets we
can
control the concentration of our
experiment in each of these droplets we
can add
samples to droplets produce are already
to to sort of mimic an assay and then we
can in cube
incubate these droplets either on the
chip or off the chip
for our assay to take place
then uh depending on our assay uh
we can have a variety of different types
of sensors so here we are showing
capacitive sensing and fluorescent
sensing
uh um where we're basically we can have
a readout
of how where how well our candidate has
uh
sort of carried out that essay
and then finally depending on our
readouts
we can sort the droplets that
are behaved in an interesting way or in
a desirable way
to sort of see or fish out
those kinetic circuits that gave rise to
that
interesting behavior so
with that you would expect a sort of uh
most sensitive biology labs to be just
filled with high throughput screening
platform just running non-stop
uh doing these uh doing these sort of
screens to see what candidates work the
best
however we see that's really uh an
exception rather than being the norm
and um we can sort of contribute several
reasons for it
uh one part is fabricating these
microflip devices
are expensive they require a good amount
of
expertise and experience and also they
require some
facilities or infrastructure like a
clean room facility
and even if you want to have integrated
electrodes in them your
your fabrication becomes even more
challenging and more
uh expensive uh we we don't know
a lot about the fluid dynamics of my
microfluidics specifically multi-phase
flows
or droplet-based microfluidics uh so
so we don't understand the fluid
dynamics uh that well and also
there's not a lot of characterization
data sort of out there in the literature
and people
mostly publish on sort of the one
optimized device that works and
leave out a sort of lots of
characterization data
so um in your typical microfluidic
device if you want to
sort of like swap out your fluids the
type of cells you use
or even if uh you just change your
surfactants
your microfluid device might not work
sort of optimally or
might stop working altogether
and also we don't have any uh sort of
microfluidic specific uh design tool or
design automation tools for example here
uh on the figure on the bottom right
you're seeing a microwave device with
more than
4 000 components on it and all of them
has been
manually drawn and sort of
all of these together make a fabricating
microfleece device to be an iterative
costly and time-consuming process with
if you want to fabricate it in house
it's uh it's going to be a little bit
more than 200 to 500
uh and it could take days if you want to
order it or outsource it
then these numbers would rise
even higher so um
our goal was to address
a part of this by developing a software
tool
for design automation of droplet
generators specifically flow focusing
droplet generators
so the idea is a user can go to our
software or our website
and specify a desired droplet diameter
and a generation rate
and then we'll use some machine learning
algorithms
on the back end to sort of suggest a
geometry
and also the flow rates the user needs
to run that device
at to achieve their desired performance
in terms of
the droplet diameter and generation rate
so
to achieve design automation the first
the first step is to uh to sort of
develop performance prediction meaning
that
if we have our design parameters
including our geometry and flow
condition
we want to be able to predict the
droplet size and
generation rate as we
as we talked about it before uh
the fluid dynamics of droplet-based uh
microfluidic devices
is complex and neural networks are ideal
tools for
uh sort of understanding and having a
sort of like a predictive model
of complex phenomena and here so we want
to
develop a neural network that can take
all the six geometric parameters of flow
focusing device
and the two flow condition parameters
and then be able to
predict the droplet diameter and the
generation rate so
the one downside to neural networks is
it requires a lot of data and as we
talked about it
fabricating myfit devices traditionally
is an expensive
procedure so it's not really uh uh
data generation friendly so
um we developed this uh a sort of
low-cost
uh rapid prototyping for microfluidics
where we
take advantage of a new class of cnc
mills that cost
less than three thousand dollars uh and
then male microflight
geometries out of thermoplastics
specifically
uh polycarbonate here and then we can
use uh
sort of an elastic membrane in between
with
clamps or use uh double-sided adhesives
or even chemical bonding
uh to sort of seal our microfluidic
devices and
with this method we can fabricate
microfluidic devices with features
as small as 75 microns
also they would cost less than 10 each
and it requires less than two hours to
fabricate
a device so now that we have a low cost
rapid prototyping method
on hand we can go about our challenge
of creating lots of data
so we we took a microfluidic
flow focusing geometry and created large
variations
of the geometry changed all the
geometric parameters
and fabricated close to 45 different
flow focusing devices
and then each of those devices would
test as a wide range of capillary
numbers
and floor ratio to to sort of create
this
large-scale data set so how does our
our data set look well uh we we have
close to
a thousand total uh data points with
almost
approximately equal number of data
points in the dripping
and the jetting regime as you can see
on the figure on the bottom left so
we have our data set now now
the question needs to be asked well how
will do machine learning models
uh predict the performance of flow
focusing devices
um so here on the graphs what you are
looking at
on the x-axis is going to be the
observed performance
and on the y-axis it's going to be the
predicted performance so drop the
diameter or generation
and in an ideal scenario we want all of
these dots to sort of like
line up on the y equals x line and you
can see
our neural networks are doing a really
good job of uh predicting the
performance of slow focusing devices
an observation can be made that we can
predict uh drop the diameter with a
higher accuracy
in comparison to generation rate
so to give you an idea of how well
these models are predicting the
performance of flow focusing devices
we have this comparison of the
previously proposed scaling laws
uh for flow focusing geometries and you
can see
uh uh in drought for predicting droplet
diameter
they're not as accurate and in the
generation rate there's
uh there's really not a lot of
performance prediction going on at all
on for the scaling lot
and in scaling law of defense they're
not really meant for accurate
performance prediction they're meant for
understanding the high-level dynamics of
the system and
the only reason we're comparing them
right now is because of the lack of any
other sort of tool to compare it to
and um now that we have performance
prediction we actually made it into a
software
and also an online website so you can
actually go to our website
dapdcad.org and you can sort of input
the the device parameters of your flow
focusing geometry
and we're able to predict how well uh
we were able to predict the droplet
diameter and the generation rate
on average we saw a mean absolute error
of less than 10 microns
for predicting the diameter and less
than 20 hertz for
uh predicting the generation rate so
now that we have uh accurate performance
prediction
um now that we have accurate performance
prediction on hand
uh now it's time to sort of like tackle
the main challenge
uh we we sort of wanted to solve which
was design automation where a user
provides
their desired droplet diameter and
generation rate
and we're able to suggest the design
that delivers that performance
so
to to achieve this design automation we
actually
came up with a relatively uh
word algorithm where uh when a user
specifies their
desired uh performance we look through
our data set
and then find a data point in there that
has the closest performance
to the desired performance specified by
the user
each device has eight different
parameters so we're going to tweak those
parameters a little bit each
by increasing and decreasing them by
normalized and equal steps creating 16
new designs
then we use our neural networks to
predict the performance of
all of these newly generated designs and
the one that got us closest
to the desired performance will be uh
sort of taken as a starting point
for our second iteration so we'll
continue this process
until our neural networks are able to
sort of find a design
that accurately uh sort of
delivers the desired performance so how
well
uh does it work
um so at the first step to sort of test
this
we use our software to specify uh just
drop a diameter
uh ranging from droplet sizes of
25 microns all the way up to 200 microns
and then we fabricated and tested the
device that was suggested by the
software
and as you can see on on the figure
where we're keeping a really good trend
of of delivering the drop of diameter
that was specified by the user in
addition
you can also specify droplet diameter
and generation rate at the same time
so for these graphs we are specifying a
droplet diameter of 100 microns
and a generation rate ranging from
50 droplets per second all the way up to
uh
500 droplets per second and
well we can do the same thing for a drop
of diameter of 75 microns the same
generation rates and dropped the
diameter of 50 microns
with the same generation rates and sort
of to summarize these
in numbers on average we observed an
experimental error
of around 5 for uh for the
for the droplet diameter and around ten
percent for the generation rate so
if user specifies the droplet diameter
and generation rate
we're able to deliver that performance
uh
uh with an average error of five percent
and uh ten percent for drop diameter and
uh generation rate uh respectively
so uh we made this also into a software
where you can go to our website and
specify your
desired diameter and generation rate and
hit generation
hit generate design and you can see you
get your
geometry you can also open that design
in a software created
in our lab called three dev and then
download that design
in a format of svg files that you can
directly load to the software that
controls the cnc mill
now you have to fill around with the
settings a little bit just to make sure
your g-codes
are placed correctly but then you can
rapidly prototype that
microflip device and assemble it
as you can see here and then that device
would deliver that desired performance
so here we wanted 50 hertz and 150
microns 150 hertz
and as you can see we're getting really
close to that you can also have some
design constraints for example for
single cell encapsulation we want our
device to be as
shallow as possible uh so here we're
doing an aspect ratio of one which is
the minimum in our software
to keep the cells in the uh and the sort
of the plane of focus you can see an
entirely new design is suggested for the
same performance
it can also give you the cell
concentration you need to run your
experiment at
and you can see we're getting single
cell encapsulation and also we're
getting droplet diameters of
46.3 microns and 167 hertz
uh which is a basically really close to
our desired performance so
we can have uh design automation with or
without constraints
it is an online tune and also uh and
also uh
we can sort of calculate the the cell
concentrations you need to
run your experiments at to achieve a
single cell encapsulation
so when you use our software and specify
your desired
performance a design will be suggested
to you
and uh the the sort of the performance
you're going to get out of that device
is going to be ultimately
dependent on the tolerances in your
fabrication and
also testing meaning how accurate your
pumps are
and using our neural networks we're
actually able to
predict how these tolerances would
affect your
observed performance for example here
we're assuming your tolerance
your fabrication has about 10 percent
error in
uh and sort of spatial accuracy so so we
can predict
how having an oil and lip width 10
larger or smaller
would affect your uh observed droplet
diameter
we can also do this uh sort of very
efficiently for
uh all of the other design parameters
for both droplet diameter and generation
rate
and creating these sort of like
tolerance plots
that you can use to understand how
tolerances and fabrication
will affect your observed performance we
can also use these
information provided here to identify
what are the main parameters you have to
care about or make sure you're doing
accurately
to achieve that to achieve that desired
performance for example in in the case
that we are showing here
for droplet diameter your oil inlet
width is the most dominant parameter
so once you fabricate your device you
just want to make sure to look at the
device under the microscope make sure
your inlet width
is what we are suggesting
and then you should be good to go uh
another
observation that can be made here is um
these dominant parameters will change
based on
what is your design and what is your
desired performance so it's not going to
be
always take a look at the oil in a
little bit sometimes going to be the
orifice or
other parameters and that goes to show
like uh
the the the sort of the the level of uh
sophistication a design automation tool
like this can bring
that gives you performance specific
information on your device and how you
should fabricate it
and then ultimately we can also use our
neural networks to predict how
changing the flow rates uh increasing
both the fluid florida oil and water
would affect your droplet diameter and
generation rate so
in case if you have tolerances in your
fabrication
you can use these plots as for
as guidelines to bring different the
observed performance
back to your desired performance so
all of this is great but well how
generalizable
is it so traditionally
or with traditional machine learning
let's say we we required 500 data points
to develop an
accurate neural network that can predict
the performance of droplet generation
and if you want to change your oil or if
you want to change
uh your fluid from one type to another
one would expect you would need another
500 data points
to sort of achieve the same level of
performance accuracy
however with uh
with transfer learning um
since the high level dynamics of droplet
generation would stay the same
regardless of the types of fluids you
can use we can do the generalizability
from one fluid to another
much more efficiently and if we have
a model already trained on
droplet generation then we can
generalize that
uh with significantly fewer number of
data points to
uh to to new fluids and you can think
about it
as this way it would be much easier to
understand or to learn how to
ride a motorcycle if you already know
how to ride a bike
and the way transfer learning itself
works
it's actually uh pretty simple so assume
a typical
feed forward neural network
and what's generally agreed upon is
the first few hidden layers carry the
more generic
information to your system so this is
going to be
if your neural network is like a
classifier for
like cats versus dog or is it a model
for predicting
the performance of droplet generation
and the last few hidden layers
uh carry more specific information so
this could be about
your fluid properties or the the sort of
the material properties used for
your microfluidic devices to create
these droplets so
in transfer learning what we do is we
don't allow the first few hidden layers
to be updated when we are training our
model so
we just keep the keep those layers as
frozen layers
and just allow the last couple of hidden
layers to be updated to our new system
and because we don't really require to
train for so many
additional weights now we only need a
few weights to be updated
on our neural network this requires uh
much
much fewer uh data points so to see if
actually transfer learning uh works in
droplet microflicks what we did
is uh if you remember we had a large
scale data set
on on generating droplets using gi water
and
nf 350 mineral oil so to test the
applicability of transfer learning and
droplet generation we created
two new small scale data sets the first
one
we swapped out dli water for lv
bacterial media
and produced droplets with lb bacterial
media
creating about 36 data points and then
in our second small scale data set
we change the oil from nf-350 mineral
oil
to light mineral oil and the viscosity
difference between these two oils
is actually a factor of two so these
oils are
significantly different uh in their
fluid property
and as you can see when training neural
networks from scratch
our models are not really doing a good
job on on accurately predicting the
performance for these small scale data
sets and that's sort of given
because nobody expecting uh neural
networks to
work uh good with uh only having like 40
or 20 data points
however when we use transfer learning
and update our pre-trained modeled with
this new small scale data sets
we can see our models are doing a much
much better job in comparison to
training from scratch when using
uh transfer landing so we have done
sort of the heavy lifting on
understanding or capturing the high
level dynamics of droplet generation
with a large-scale data set
and now uh us or or different users can
create these small-scale data sets of
let's say
40 50 or something around that data
points
to uh sort of generalize this and update
our models to
to sort of uh be able to predict the
performance of droplet generators
for uh different types of fluids
so everything we talked about today was
about a single component in a single
type of
uh of in a single type of microwave so
we're doing
uh design automation for specifically
flow focusing droplet generators
and uh there are so many different
components in just throughout the
microwave
itself and also there are so many
different kinds of microwaves like
inertial microfluidics acoustic
microfluidics
or capillary microfluidics so
this cannot be done by a single person
single lab or even a single institution
and it really requires a sort of a
community
of people sort of to start working
together to share data and also
create open source uh tools like uh like
dfd
um that can uh sort of uh really
accelerate the
uh the the sort of the design process in
microfluidics and then enable
uh sort of downstream processes like
synthetic biology that we talked about
earlier that could really benefit
from not having to spend too much time
on developing
microfluidic devices so towards this end
we made sure all of our software is open
source
and also all of the data we created can
be
freely accessed and downloaded on our
website so
make sure to check out our website our
lab website ciderlab.org
our tool website daptycad.org and if
you're interested to see
sort of our source code you can go to
our github
as well so uh with that i would like to
uh
thank my pi dr doug densmore my great
colleagues at ciderlab and damplab
and also uh man my funding
a set of agencies and with that i would
like to uh thank you all for your time
and attention